Hey
San Francisco is a vast multicultural
City and its residents reflect that in
the most interesting ways from dancing
art culture music family costumes
BDSM and what the [ __ ] San Fran's got it
all so come join us as we go on a selfie
journey and watch dogs - this city is
all about family and you'll get that
vibe the moment you go outside San Fran
is well known for its art and you can
see that anywhere on the streets walk
down an alleyway and you'll be treated
to an artist's wet dream
Wow music and dance go hand-in-hand here
in this city and no matter what you're
into seriously we won't judge you'll
find something to bust a move to hear
culture is the lifeblood of the city
from its heat watch jeez sorry mix of
religions to its beautiful parks and the
people who live in them Oh yep even this
guy so what you're tired of car surfing
drone taunting starting fights
and tasing naked people take a step back
and have a look at the city for what it
has to offer you for more on watchdogs -
keep it here on gamespot